the police search for Nicola began
within hours she was considered high
risk for reasons that became clear much
later
her family clung to Hope
obviously my hope is that she's still
out there she's Sonic's happened and
she's
I don't know needed to take herself off
for whatever reason and we just want a
home we need to we need her home her
children need a home
Nicola's friends launched their own
appeal for information
urging witnesses to come forward
a week on police revealed their thinking
it does remain our belief
that Nicola sadly fell into the river
and that this is a missing person
inquiry there was a lot of river to
search a tidal flow 12 miles to the sea
in morkan Bay
but there were no clues there either
the family brought in an independent
specialist he too found no sign of
Nicola in a stretch of river he searched
it is as though
she had vanished Into Thin Air like
yeah just it I'm just insane
by then the investigation was attracting
amateur sleuths some of them live
streamed their own theories on social
media
to try to stop wild speculation police
revealed why they had graded Nicola high
risk
as soon as she was reported missing
provided to the police by her partner
Paul
and based on a number of specific
vulnerabilities that we were made aware
of Nicola was graded as high risk
later police explained Nicola's
vulnerability they said she had
significant struggles with alcohol
brought on by the menopause
the Revelation sparked widespread
condemnation even from 10 Downing Street
well I agree with the Home Secretary in
like her I was concerned that that
private information was put into the
public domain and I'm pleased that the
police are looking at how that happened
in the investigation
the police theory of what happened to
Nicola may have been proved right
but it will be overshadowed by their
Revelations of her personal problems
Martin brunt Sky News